please welcome animator and gold
medalist jennifer bores
oh my gosh i'm really here
um i'd like to thank the academy for
bringing departure of love all the way
here to be shown alongside the works of
these incredible filmmakers
and i'm honored to have had the
opportunity of meeting each of you this
week
and it's really a dream come true
i'd like to dedicate this award to all
those at the ringling college of art and
design who've worked right beside me
with the most passion and dedication
to succeed in the major
and i've had the pleasure of watching
each of them grow into the genuine
artists and filmmakers they are today
and i'd like to thank my friends and
family who never questioned me in the
career i wanted to pursue
but always stood beside me
with the love and support that i needed
and to my mom and dad and four wonderful
wonderful brothers thank you for
showing me how important it is to have
faith and apply it to every part of my
life
to be sure that i love every moment of
what i do
but more importantly to always do good
and keep changing the world for the
better thank you